[Music]
some of us are born with a particular
set of skills spotting the yokai coming
closer and closer
to jaws music amplifies but now in the
hallway that's four for polo
will he get the ace turning the corners
give him the ace put it in the montage
tsm
of 2-0 there is an innate talent that
manifests itself at a young age
a god-given mastery of a game that can
carry you through even the craziest
situations
renee bid alem is able to survive as uh
p4 will go down shaikh will able to pick
up a double kill there
he's not gonna be able to land the third
one yes he does scheiker with a quad
but for most of us the grind is what
gets us to where we want to be
and the earlier we start the higher our
chances are
to well get good if i get stuck
dude
i will cry and for those of us fighting
to survive
in games where we lack natural ability
and experience
the intuition is to seek guidance from
others who can save us
from ourselves
but what if i told you that in the
rainbow six siege community
players weren't only lining up for
advice
dished out by prodigious zoomers that
instead they were
most likely learning to play the game
from a filthy casual
turned hardcore content creator by the
name
of dylan get flanked clark an ambitious
old fella who
saw the seemingly insurmountable
learning curve of rainbow six siege
as just another barrier that was meant
to be broken
tell me if this looks
so this is how we're gonna play today
siege this is the game we're playing
today
and amazingly not only has he managed to
overcome
all of the challenges presented to him
in one of esports's most
unforgiving games he's turned it into
something
life-changing imagine you know you're in
your 30s you have two kids you have
a mortgage and everything and going to
your partner and being like hey i'm
gonna give up this very secure
very stable job and i'm gonna go after
my dream which is content creation
so what exactly drove a family man to
abandon a steady career in favor of
saving matchmaking mouth breathers and
how did this certifiable
boomer become one of the most
recognizable and influential figures in
rainbow six siege
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so if you are unacquainted with my
boy flanked you should know that he is a
man of
many talents he's a trained military
aircraft mechanic
a one-man band
[Music]
and he absolutely loves playing against
cheaters
oh my god why you don't see that
all joking aside over the last few years
flanked has essentially cemented himself
as the unofficial
sherpa of the siege community a trusted
voice of reason for noobs
everywhere who are just trying to
navigate the perils of a
brutally unforgiving game what am i
dying from
i gotta electrocute it or something
but before he had more than half a
million dedicated disciples on youtube
flanked was just a regular family man
who casually gamed on console when he
wasn't serving in the army national
guard you know i've been playing video
games
my whole life but worked on content
creation while doing that
there was a pretty about a two year
overlap there where i was creating
content and doing army
initially flanked began dabbling with
content creation back in 2015
primarily posting call of duty tips and
tricks videos
but towards the beginning of 2017 he
began investing more of his time into a
game that he
dabbled with in beta a couple of years
prior one that would end up changing his
life
forever what is up guys i'm get flanked
and today we're gonna talk about some
rainbow six
siege i'm gonna tell you guys why you
should be playing this game and what
you're missing if you're not
for flanked siege was an exciting
prospect in that it combined the
frenetic pace of call of duty with the
depth of a moba
all the while encouraging player
creativity through its unique take on
map destruction
siege was calculated chaos with a
devilish helping of cheese that
made it every bit as frustrating as it
was
glorious okay i see him
no i've been hit as well
why as dramatic as this sounds i think
there is some truth to it i mean when
you go through the army you take some
punishment and
you know you stick with it and you don't
quit and you keep
trying to persevere and when you first
start rainbow six siege
you take some punishment it's been
called the dark souls of fps's for a
reason i mean it's a very punishing game
with a very steep learning curve
and if you're somebody who gives up
easily you probably will go
and never play it again after you die to
a you know a bullet hole
uh one time over the course of the next
year more and more noobs began flocking
to flank's channel for guidance
and before long he'd amassed a sizeable
enough following to consider content
creation as
more than just a hobby but for somebody
who was already considered to be
past it by video game standards and had
a house and a family to take care of
the decision to become a full-time
content creator was
a bit of a gamble my wife is a saint
imagine
you're in your 30s you have two kids you
have a mortgage and everything and going
to your
your partner and being like hey i'm
going to give up this very secure
very stable job and i'm gonna go after
my dream which is content creation
having somebody who believes in you
enough to actually say yes to that
is uh really special and something that
i will uh
thank her for and forever being her debt
for you know there were definitely a lot
of
uh raised eyebrows whenever i said hey
i'm not going to be an aircraft mechanic
anymore i'm going to do youtube
full-time but you know i've been doing
it
full-time for almost three years now and
i think that
the longer it goes on the more they
realize okay this isn't just some
type of crazy thing this is something
that he's actually good at but a career
change
was only one of the challenges that
flanked would have to overcome
you see after playing games on console
for longer than a lot of his viewers had
been alive he opted to make the move to
pc
to hang out with the big fish and really
up his game you know learning the
keyboard after spending my whole life
on console i never played any pc games
uh really i mean no no first person
shooters on
on pc at all learning the keyboard was
tough and
you know there's a whole different speed
to the game on pc compared to
console so that adjustment was
challenging as well
eventually after hours and hours of
honing his mouse and keyboard skills
his efforts began to pay off he managed
to pull himself
up through the ranks into platt and all
the while he documented his discoveries
to help others follow in his footsteps
from the beginning of making videos to
now
that's always been what it is you know
what
what am i going through as a player what
am i learning what lessons am i learning
and how can i
pass those along to the audience so that
maybe that
their learning curve is a little shorter
than mine and they don't have to go
through the same painful lessons that i
did oh
how do i shoot that how do i drink that
freaking lie
[Music]
unreal no
[Laughter]
oh my god now flanked will be the first
to tell you that he isn't some
bolo flicking ground knifing reddit
worshiped aim god
but that doesn't mean that his
contributions to the community have gone
unnoticed by his peers keflang's really
important to the community because he
covers
every single type of gamer that plays
siege
he's extremely knowledgeable and he
explains things extremely clearly
which sometimes i have a hard time doing
so i think that he's definitely like an
amazing go-to person for anybody
no matter what type of player you are i
think one of the biggest things that he
does
he takes concepts and and things in the
game that are kind of
i guess more complex for people and
breaks them down for like the
the average player in siege i guess it's
really easy to have the knowledge
for stuff if you just play a lot or you
play at a high level and stuff like that
but it's a lot harder to
teach people i guess right it's like why
teachers are so important a lot of
people might have the knowledge for
something but it's
a whole nother thing to actually teach
someone how to do it but as the old
saying goes
no good deed goes unpunished and in a
world where seemingly
everyone on reddit is some champion
ranked aim god with an
unquestionably large e peen flank has
gotten a lot of [ __ ] from people
for not being something that he never
claimed to be
i don't feel like i'm very good at the
game i think flank is probably better
than me so
i don't know but at the same time
flanked also doesn't claim to be
bolo he doesn't claim to be godly he's
not he's not false advertising himself
like his videos aren't titled like
i'm the best siege champion on the
planet like
he's very upfront with everybody about
how he is how he plays his mindset
in fact flank's reputation as this
thoughtful
patient player who personally
experienced
all the challenges of ranking up has
made him the perfect go-between for the
casual player
the competitive player and ubisoft i
think that perspective that i have
when speaking for the casual community
is grounded in
realism that you need the casual
community in order for this game to
survive and
the fact of the matter is if you don't
have a casual community the pros
that might criticize that casual
community perspective are unemployed
within
a year or so but even if you don't agree
with every spicy take that flanked fires
off into the salty ether of siege
it's hard to dispute that he has the
game's best interest at heart
not only has he offered constructive
suggestions to make the game a better
overall experience for players of all
ranks
he's been able to directly draw
ubisoft's attention to issues like the
annoying epidemic of mouse and keyboard
players on console
and even completely overlooked game
breaking bugs
the cavera that felt very nerve-wracking
because
i found it and then i uploaded it and
then i saw the reaction to it and i
didn't really realize how big of a deal
it was
until i started seeing the reaction
there was definitely a moment of kind of
oh my goodness what have i done that
didn't feel great necessarily but the
fact that
in the long term it got fixed because of
it and the fact that i
found something that was in the game
that so many millions of people have
been playing
in the time span that that's been out
and never noticed
it's kind of a cool feeling no doubt
about it but maybe the most refreshing
thing about flank
is the fact that he's able to criticize
siege which
does have its fair share of problems all
while being
respectful and level-headed about it and
that's definitely something that the
siege community at large
could learn from i think he's a lot
better than an average player he's just
like a regular siege player
he enjoys the game he likes it for what
it is and he wants it to be better
like all of us do um he's probably a
little bit nicer about those things the
way he says them than i do than i do
but yeah i mean we all want the same
thing right we all want
the game to be better in the long term
we all go about that in like our
i guess our own ways and uh yeah i think
he does a
pretty good job of it overall and it's
it's nice that he has like the devs on
especially too like that's a huge thing
to be able to like hear their
perspectives
and honestly that is the beauty of a guy
like flanked
despite the growth of his channel the
improvement of his rank
and taking up social media
responsibilities for dark zero esports
he's never forgotten where he came from
and that maturity is something that's
only earned him affection
from his fans two different people make
personalized pens for me pins
that's that's a pretty touching
experience i've had people you know send
me emails saying that i've got them out
of a dark place
that i've helped them you know coop with
their anxiety or you know a rough point
in their life
people talked about how you know they've
related with me because i'm you know a
little bit older and it's helped them
bond with you know their son or their
daughter and and get into the you know
the same things that
that they they've been interested in um
you know that stuff has been very
touching
and thanks to his positive attitude and
dedication to making the siege community
better
a world of incredible opportunities have
presented themselves to him that
might not have had he not dared to dream
oh flanked with the move double kill for
him on the round he's warming up
at the end of the day a lot can be
learned from get flank's crazy journey
into the world of content creation
his story is a testament to the idea
that it's never too
late to pursue your passions in life and
maybe
just maybe turn them into something more
and through his continued dedication to
siege
and his role as a humble ambassador for
its casual player base
he keeps the game he loves alive and
well
for the rest of us i guess at the at the
end of the day if there's one thing that
i want people to get from me i just hope
that
i hope that i enhance their enjoyment in
the game
and that by watching my content it draws
a deeper connection
with them and something that makes them
passionate about what i am as well
in other words people criticize flanked
for not being the very thing that he
never claimed to be
yeah they're like oh you're not as good
as bolo and he's like i
like
crushed it lad that's
[Music]
a
it